perhaps it's pictures like these from
india
that sparked a change of heart
[Music]
the u.s announced its support for waving
vaccine patients on wednesday
soon after the eu said that it too would
be willing to talk about it
wealthy and industrialized countries
have long opposed such a move
but brussels may join washington in
reversing course
the european union is also ready
to discuss any proposal that address
the crisis for months aid organizations
have raised
the alarm about how vaccines have been
distributed
with poorer and middle-income countries
left behind
we need our governments to push the
vaccine manufacturers
to transfer the technology to transfer
the know-how
and to help other manufacturers around
the world scale up production
but the pharmaceutical industry sees
things differently
they say producing vaccines is a highly
complex process
and that allowing the vaccines to be
replicated by others
could impact their safety and quality
what happens now is in the hands of the
wto
but a quick decision appears unlikely
let's discuss this further with dr amesh
adalja
a senior scholar at the johns hopkins
university center for health
security he joins us from pittsburgh in
the u.s
warm welcome to you to the program does
waving vaccine patents solve the problem
of getting the vaccines out it
absolutely does not because you have to
remember this waiver
is a process that's going to take
several months to unfold it has to be
approved by member countries
and is going to be something that if it
does occur is going to be long after
vaccine supply has likely gotten better
what we need to do now is to remove the
supply chain disruptions that are going
on there are many countries that have
export restrictions
so we can't sell vaccines to some of
these countries can't get vaccines to
them that's what needs to happen this is
sort of a solution
in in search of a problem because what
we're seeing here is
an effort to undermine the whole
innovation
platform for developing vaccines like
the cova vaccine itself
and i think that that precedent is
something that is very dangerous and
needs to be
needs to be stopped is this
an issue of timing for example would
this have been fine earlier in the
pandemic or are you saying this
shouldn't have been an option at all
this shouldn't have been an option at
all intellectual property is basically
the cornerstone for how we develop
innovative products
and remember the modena vaccine they've
not enforced their patent
since the very beginning of their
vaccination program
yet there are no other companies that
make the moderna vaccine so this really
isn't about
to me access to vaccines because they're
being held up patents aren't the reason
why the world isn't vaccinated patents
are the reason why we even have covet 19
vaccines
um we have seen you mentioned supply
chain issues for example in the eu
uh where there simply have not been
enough vaccines produced um
that is not just an export issue this is
production so how would that problem be
solved
what we really have to do is prioritize
vaccines
and have to develop a manufacturing base
in these in countries that need to
to to vaccinate their populations i
think that's not necessarily an
intellectual property issue that's
building capacity to be able to have the
know-how to manufacture at a rapid pace
to have manufacturing at a high level of
quality it's not something that can be
done overnight and it's not something
that you can do just from having the
recipe for the pfizer vaccine
views from the developing world um say
that the the idea of
waving uh the the the um
patent protection is a step in the right
direction the director
of the africa centers for disease
control and prevention
called the decision quote an act a great
act of humanity are you saying this
is a misguided uh would you be saying
this is a misguided view
i do think it is a misguided view this
is very short range because
what many of these ideas kind of are
premised on is that these vaccines are
just there for the taking
that they don't require effort that they
don't require mental
uh mental concentration mental uh these
are products of people's minds that they
just don't
appear and if we remove those incentives
if we remove the ability of
companies to invest and plan and think
about what how they can offset those
risks because they think they're going
to get revenue because of the patent
protection
who's going to want to innovate in this
field anymore who's going to want to
enter into these agreements during
pandemics
if at the end this can be just taken
away from them
so i think that's that what they're not
seeing they're not seeing this long
range and
and and i think that's what we have to
to really combat because if we lose
the ability to innovate and have the
biopharmaceutical companies
develop products that all our lives
depend on we're all going to be worse
off i think we can solve covet 19
without
violating intellectual property rights
that was a mesh adulterer from the johns
hopkins
university center for health security